so
last monday we got that awesome new
captain marvel full trailer and we got
an awesome glimpse at
just how strong she can be and then this
past weekend at cc xp in sao paulo
brazil we
got the trailer description for
spider-man far from home
tom holland and jake gyllenhaal
themselves actually showed up to present
the trailer
and although sony actually has not
released it anywhere yet we got the
descriptions from the fans that were in
attendance so it seems like spider-man
far from home sort of stole the show at
ccxp
but brie larson was there and there was
a lot of talk about captain marvel as
well
in fact it seems like brie larson could
have given away a very
specific scene that could happen in
avengers 4
concerning thor's hammer at cc xp brie
larson actually confirmed that captain
marvel can in fact lift thor's hammer
one nerdy question for you okay do you
think captain marvel
is able to lift taurus hammer she's
worthy
definitely yes so as you can see in this
interview brie larson
is 100 confident that captain marvel can
lift thor's hammer
and this is most likely due to the fact
that she probably will lift thor's
hammer at some point in avengers end
game
keep in mind that thor's current hammer
is stormbreaker and not mjolnir
with mjolnir you had to be worthy enough
to lift the hammer
this was the enchantment put on it by
odin whoever holds this hammer
if he be worthy she'll possess the power
of thor
but with stormbreaker we know that there
is no worthiness enchantment put
on this and we know this because the
russo brothers have come out and said
this
and in avengers infinity war when thor
is talking to the guardians of the
galaxy about going to neda velire and
forging stormbreaker quill tells thor
that they should all have thanos killing
weapons and thor replies
you simply lack the strength to wield it
your bodies would crumble as your minds
collapsed into madness wait what kind of
what kind of weapon are we talking about
here the thanos killing kind
don't you think that we should all have
a weapon like that so we know that
lifting stormbreaker has nothing to do
with worthiness but has everything to do
with strength and stormbreaker was a
weapon that is meant for the king of
asgard
so you'd need some substantial strength
to be able to lift stormbreaker you'd
need to be a god basically
but captain marvel is supposed to be one
of the strongest characters in the mcu
when she enters it
not to mention her powers are vastly
multiplied when she goes into her binary
mode so when it comes down to strength
we know that captain marvel can
in fact lift stormbreaker and judging by
brie larson's reaction to the question
if captain marvel can lift stormbreaker
and the smirk on her face i'd say that
she probably does in fact lift it at
some point in avengers end game which is
why she's so confident when she answers
this question
so captain marvel has the strength to
lift stormbreaker but
do you think we'll see it happen in
avengers in game let me know your
thoughts and your theories in the
comments down below
and i'm still giving away a life-size
infinity gauntlet all you have to do to
enter for your chance to win is be
subscribed to my channel like this video
and comment down below with your
thoughts and your favorite superhero and
don't forget to subscribe with the
notifications turned on so you can stay
up to date on everything related to
captain marvel and avengers end game
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof
[Music]
you